guys I just had a birthday on Saturday
clap for me thank you yeah I bought
myself a gym membership cuz I didn't
work out at all last year I had a
boyfriend who loved me for who I was and
I took it as a challenge I was like okay
let's see how much you mean it so I'm
single now but I won I do want to get
married though because y'all I got bills
I went to pay my Macy's credit card bill
online and they had just updated their
sights you had to choose like all new
security questions just to log back into
your account but all the choices were
like I spouse's mother's name city you
got engaged in year you got married and
I was like do you want the money or not
Macy's if you want the money you got to
ask some single lady questions like how
many cats is too many cats who is your
favorite golden girl last time you
shaved above the knee at his home yeah I
went to a wedding where the groom in the
couple was gonna take the bride's last
name I thought wow that is super
feminist but like I don't want my future
husband to be quite that feminist cuz
the few changes his last name to my last
name how will people know I got married
like at my age like 99% of getting
married is changing your last name so
other people know someone loves you now
I want to change mine so bad that like
if I married a guy whose last name was
already Jackson I would still - a no
Jackson Jackson is not a type
googled my high-school arch-nemesis yeah
first result was a mug shot made my day
I was just hoping she got fat too but
prison yeah I felt like I won the
Powerball
you know I am Petty and filled with hay
I hope grudges forever and people say
Erin that's not healthy you got to let
that negative energy go but it brings me
joy like if I if I thought I could earn
a living holding grudges this would be
like my late night debut and my
retirement Chuck no I would I would open
up my own grudge and just sitting there
like just from 9:00 to 5:00 every day
and just hold on to them I would I
probably would even take a lunch break
cuz they hate will fill me up is what
I'm saying I would take over other
people's grudges like a sublet like you
could come into my grudge but give me
give me money and the backstory and now
hey who you hate for you take a day off
cuz I am NOT a good person I was in
Starbucks and the guy the table next to
me asked me if I would watch his laptop
make sure nobody stole it while he went
to the bathroom and I was like no I
can't commit to that I don't know you
like if someone runs in that Starbucks
like give me the laptop I'm gonna give
them that laptop like I'm not trying to
be a hero watch it it's outside now I'm
trying to eat healthier but it's hard
because I travel so much for work like
I'll buy a bunch of green stuff and then
I'll go out of town for we could come
back everything in the fridge is almost
spoiled you know that never happened
when I did my grocery shopping at Rite
Aid I'm just saying
but I was telling the friend recently I
said I don't think I've ever finished
eating a bunch of bananas before they
turn brown like ever and he was a quite
Arian you just got to buy fewer bananas
at a time and I was like I can't cuz
they come together in a bun and he said
yeah but you could pull apart just buy
what you need and I did not know you
could do that guys my whole life I've
been weighing bunches of bananas trying
to find a lighter bunch if I didn't want
to pay the amount on the scale I don't
know I didn't know you could manually
adjust the banana bunch of poundage and
I have wanted to I have been and it
grocery store before like I really only
need 3 bananas but I know they got
cameras in here like that is not a
gangster prison story like hey what you
in for you already got me on the Nana's
son
[Applause]
you